so III is over and this is the most
information will have on Dark Souls 2
for a while so watch this video if you
want an idea of what Dark Souls 2 is
shaping up to be if at any point you're
not interested in what I'm talking about
just check the description and skip
ahead to something more interesting
so the demos at e3 were difficult really
difficult like only one journalist
defeated the boss tear difficult
journalists got to choose from a
selection of class types warrior
sorcerer temple knight and duel
swordsman so they played through a
single stretch of the game bleeding
towards the Maronite boss some people
played for a couple of hours and only
one guy defeated the Maronite however
this could be just a tribute to how bad
some journalists are in video games
anyway I mentioned warping and warping
between lit bonfires is now available
from the start of the game this is true
reduce some of the tedium that people
complained about so it's sort of trim
some of the fat
but don't worry devs made it clear that
this is where the accessibility stops
and it's been great to read some of the
experiences that came out of a 3-1
journalist speaks of happy rushed past
some apparently dead enemies which came
to life as he was further in the level
and ambushed him another praised is the
level design where you can funnel
multiple enemies into a tight corridor
but if you get pushed too far back you
get trapped
it's the souls game we know and love so
the boss at the end of the level the
mirror knight he looks like one hell of
a challenge and the most interesting
aspect of this fight happens when he
slams down his shield giving you the
opportunity to either deal damage to him
or to shatter his shield and if you
don't shatter his shield an NPC will
burst out and fight you as well if
you're playing an online mode the
character will be a real player who's
been summoned prior to the fight and
waiting to come into your fight and I'm
so hyped for that like maybe summoned
players will be able to witness the
fight as they wait for their chance to
break out of the shield
that's a cool thought the Maronite
stands at about the halfway point in the
game so that might give you an idea of
the difficulty curve it's interesting to
note that in an interview with polygon
the game's director said that he was
confused by the fears of the North
American and European audience and he
didn't really understand them he has
continually repeated his goal to improve
the features there at the core of the
souls game and one of those things is
enemy AI so let's
about that in the demo many enemies
convincingly fake death they wait for
you to pass before waking up and they
don't make a whole lot of noise about it
and this is the sort of trick you'd
expect from a Souls game but while this
new behavior is interesting there seems
to be more of a broader subtler change
to enemy AI that makes me more excited
so this was reported by a few testers
simply put enemies seem smarter they no
longer just rush you initially and a few
people made it sound like they sized you
up just like you sort of size them up
when you learn how they behave moves
that were once easy to engage and
sidestep are no longer as easy a lunge
attack for example will adjust with your
movement and track your sidestep gone
are the days of the easy back step since
enemies will pivot and track your
movement much faster so this is great
because back steps were always a really
sort of failsafe way of taking out
humanoid enemies in Dark Souls so it's
great to see that gimped a little bit
test has also noticed that enemies made
better use of their dodge ability now
I've mentioned a few times now that
enemies are sort of really situationally
aware and this is a recurring theme
enemies will push their advantage
a few play testers noticed that once
they sort of backed up to heal during a
fight that enemies wouldn't just keep
their traditional pattern of play like
when you back up to heal against a
hollow and Dark Souls it won't pursue
you any differently just like bosses
like Gwyn will become more aggressive
you too if you try to heal enemies will
now be able to sprint just like you and
if they see you fleeing to heal they
will run you down with intent so
speaking of healing it seems like
healing has also changed to suit the
gameplay if you play Demon Souls you'd
know that healing took a purely
consumable form in that game healing
items were everywhere and you could
theoretically farm a huge amount to spam
if you were having trouble with a level
in Dark Souls you go through an area
with about five flasks if you're
confident but most people probably up to
their flasks to about ten if they were
having trouble additional consumable
items like humanity existed but they
were really valuable and that had other
uses within the game so spamming them or
farming them wasn't really an option in
Dark Souls 2 we're seeing emerging of
plentiful consumables and also limited
Estus flasks so estes still exists
presumably in the same form as Dark
Souls however many enemies drop life
stones and radiant life stones which can
refill health while you walk but they
fill your health slowly they will not
save your life in a crucial moment the
same way as to saw humanity would so I
was thinking what might this mean for
the balance of the game well if you
think about it s this sort of gave you a
really controlled experience like more
of a do it right or start over because
you wasted your flasks and didn't save
enough for a boss in Demon Souls you are
more likely to die because you were
overwhelmed in one fight rather than
because you ran out of consumable
healing items because you know it was
unlikely that you'd completely run out
in Dark Souls 2 we see emerging of the
healing systems Estus fe use during
fights and consumables that will help
you maintain your health between fights
you're less likely to die because you
ran out of healing items and more likely
to die because you misjudged a combat
situation if that makes sense so to
match my theory of taking more damage
during fights and getting more healing
between them it sort of matches up with
what we've seen from the gameplay since
there's this big focus on AI and
tackling enemy interaction in a clever
and really skillful way in his
experience with the game Rubicon noted
that the combat felt heavy and intense
like every blow mattered and if you
[ __ ] up if you were hit it was really
hard to recover especially if there were
multiple enemies he also noticed that
there was a really a lot more chip
damage over time so like I said earlier
to match the new healing system it
sounds like mistakes will punish you
more and that you'll be taking a lot
more consistent damage you'll be more
likely to die in the short term because
of a serious combat mistake or a series
of combat mistakes rather than die in
the long term because you kept chugging
Estus and kept tanking hits until you
ran out of healing items so you're less
likely to die than like that in the long
term so anyway click here for part two
where I go on to talk about the new
classes like the duel swordsman how
dodging and back stabs are no longer the
same
now the torch no longer blocks 100%
physical damage and oh also how there's
no games for Windows Live logo on the
website
oh yeah and leave a like if you enjoyed
this video cheers guys I'll see you next
time